There are lots of things that regular people can do but dads can't.
Dads can't pitch a baseball very hard or hit one very far.
When dads play hide-and-seek they always get found, but they have a hard time finding you.
They aren't very good wrestlers.
Dads lose at checkers and cards and almost every other game.
Dads like to go fishing but they don't like to go alone.
And they need extra practice baiting the hook.
Dads don't seem to be able to drive very fast.
Dads seem to have trouble holding on to their money.
Dads can't see you hiding your lima beans at dinnertime or feeding them to the cat.
Dads like to give baths but they can't help getting all wet.
Dads can't read a book by themselves.
And dads really need to be kissed good night at bedtime.
There are so many things dads can't do, it's a wonder they make it through life at all!
But dads can't give up.
No matter how tired a dad gets or how hard life gets, a dad never quits.
Thanks, Dad!
Happy Father's Day!